you said you're lazy I'm I'm I'm lazy I
don't know about everybody else but like
I would rather watch Real Housewives of
Atlanta or like The Real Housewives New
Jersey one of the Real Housewives or
some or like um selling sunet on Netflix
like I just finished the entire This Is
Us series which was fantastic you know
if I could just like lay around and
watch TV all day that would be my joy
but unfortunately I can't do that I do
have to work um so I have to play a lot
of games with myself and with my own
mind to get myself to work um which
means that for me like even in my course
I teach people when they're doing
project planning um to build in their
personality to build it around your
personality and like my personality I
have to have an external Factor
demanding that whatever work I need to
do be done or it's not going to get done
and that means that I need to uh have an
audience waiting for a podcast episode
or a podcast episode's not going to get
done I have to have either a manager or
a production company or development
executive waiting for Pages for a script
or something or a course waiting for
Pages I'm taking if I'm taking a
screenwriting class if I'm trying to get
a script written a lot of times I'll
I'll take a screenwriting class so I'm
basically paying to write a script
because I know I'm so lazy that I will
not write it unless I have a class
waiting and there is a due date and
people are waiting for pages so I have
to work with my own lack of motivation
and lack of energy if I don't have
energy so that I make sure to create
because what I do know is that I don't
feel good about myself when I'm not
creating when I do give into the
laziness and I and I only watch TV all
day and I watch you know Real Housewives
of New Jersey I'm seeing Teresa getting
married and if I'm spending my time
doing this and I don't at the end of the
year have at least one original script
done then I don't feel good about myself
I don't feel good about going on
vacation I don't feel good about taking
time off because I feel guilty I feel
like I have gifts that I didn't use I
feel like I had ideas that I didn't put
out into the world that I didn't birth
and I think it's not it's not fair so I
don't I so I I have to do a lot because
I know and I remember the feeling of
what it feels like when I let myself
down so I have to work with my own
laziness by creating all kinds of
scenarios where things are due and they
need to get done and people are waiting
for them and I work backwards by like
let's say I have a due date for a course
or for a festival you know like um a
short film is due for a festival or
something like that I need to submit to
so I'll work backwards I'll be like all
right so that short film is dueing
September 15th so I'm going to put this
in my calendar I'm going to give myself
3 months I'm going to create the script
by the end of the first month I'm going
to finish producing I'm going to like
start reaching out to people to help me
produce the short film in the second
month in the third month we shoot it and
edit it and I have it ready for
September so that's kind of how I do I
work backwards like let's say if I have
an development executive ask me to get
something in in a month so I I I work
backwards I like break down my project
into small pieces over that month um to
make sure that they get it by then and I
work in small pieces like I said cuz I
can do like I feel two or three hours of
creative work a day before I'm like
really tired um so I just break it down
if I if something's doing a month I do
like four days a week uh 3 hours a day
two hours a day 1 hour a day sometimes
depending on what I'm working on if I'm
working on different projects at the
same time and and I find that for me
personally that is the best way to work
to break things down into small pieces
to have an
external uh deadline to have somebody
someone's going to be upset if if I
don't get this done um because otherwise
it won't get
done it's interesting cuz I I had
troubles watching TV as well and not
troubles but I just canceled the cable
cuz I wasn't able to have that
discipline and I found that that made me
go cold turkey oh wow
wonder you could just cancel cable cuz I
have Instagram I have YouTube I have all
sorts of other ways to I have Candy
Crush now I have so many ways to to just
like let my brain veg out if if I'm not
really like I have to have deadlines
otherwise I don't care what it is I I'd
rather scroll than actually do work yeah
it's interesting cuz it it is a thing
where there's so much coming at us where
we can find all these excuses so yeah um
this was this was before all that and so
I didn't have those different things but
then uh the neighbor had riged the cable
so I was getting it anyway I didn't know
it but what you said about like it was a
different time it's so true like to me
it feels like we're in a battle for our
attention every single day like we
really have to be vigilant about where
our attention is going and I'm saying
this as a certified lazy scroller who
would rather scroll all day than do work
like I have to be so Vigilant about
having work done and doing work and
prioritizing work like I'll literally
reward myself with scrolling or with
like right now oh my God like right now
I'm really into watching um astrology
readings on YouTube uh I'm really into
Minon tarot right now and so this
morning I had to listen to a podcast uh
uh write editing notes for it record an
intro and outro for it and just do all
the producing that I have to do for my
podcast and I needed to do it in like 2
hours that's all the time I had today
and so I put in my calendar and my
reward was watching my Libra horoscope
when I was done um and if it wasn't that
it would have been a real housewives
episode or something like that like so I
literally use I I dangle these things
like a carrot because I know that that
is what my brain wants for that
serotonin hit of like scrolling or like
you know whatever it is that my brain
wants but if I don't get this work done
then I'm not going to be happy with
myself either so I just try to have the
best of both worlds but I definitely
think that like we are in a battle for
our attention and you have to be
vigilant that's true but I like that you
give yourself rewards I know I used to
do that too where I had to get out of
the house I would go to this thrift
store where there was just all this
stuff going on and strange people and I
loved it and that was enough for me and
then I would come back home
and yes I could do work fill yourself up
yeah right you have a quote that I know
or excuse me I know you love this book
from Cal Newport and that is so good
they can't ignore you and I think you
talked about this in one of your videos
or Tik Tok something you said following
your passion is terrible advice yeah
that's like the Crux of cal newport's
book because his whole thing is that our
passion doesn't necessarily always
translate to what a good life looks like
is what he's saying in the book like uh
a lot of times like for instance people
who were really passionate about the law
they go into being a lawyer and then the
lifestyle of being a lawyer is like
really long hours like a lot of um time
spent in the office a lot of uh a lot of
work people feel really overwhelmed by
it they can't be there for their kids
they can't pick their kids up from
school and it's like you know I think
the pandemic really showed us oh if I'm
not at work I have time to do these
things like pick up my kids from school
like take my dog I take my dog to the
park I I I walk in the park in the
mornings or I have time to exercise like
there were all these things that I
didn't really have time for when I had
to go into an office and I didn't and
also there's just no way that I could
have known uh personally like for me in
my background what the day-to-day of
being a screenwriter was like I didn't
know what the hours were like and like
you just don't necessarily know if the
thing that you want to do will translate
into a lifestyle that will be fulfilling
to you um and he thinks that things like
the hours the commute um your
contribution to society these other
things matter way more than what you're
passionate about and that your passion
can be something that you do on your own
time and not necessarily something that
you get paid for um but what he teaches
you to do in the book is no matter what
to get good
at whatever it is you're good at or
whatever it is you're skilled at um so
good that you're able to dictate those
things you're able to dictate your hours
you're able to dictate your commute
you're able to dictate whether or not
you come into the office like because
what really makes us happy is agency
ultimately is what he's saying in the
book and I think it's totally true there
there were aspects of my work that I
found I felt very powerless in certain
extents particularly for instance as a
writer when you sell your idea like if I
sell my idea to Netflix Netflix now owns
that idea I now become an employee of my
own idea I'm not the owner of this
anymore Netflix is the owner like I'm I
essentially get paid a check for my own
idea if I'm the showrunner of my own
idea I'm running an entire production
and I'm still not really the boss I
still have to answer to the executives
in Netflix I have to maybe there's
another outside Studio that's involved
you know so there's all these people
that you have to answer to um
but you might not know that and you
might not love that and you and that's
something that you don't necessarily
know coming in I now know that I'm
somebody who really likes having full
control of what I'm doing I'm somebody
who likes having a lot of control over
my time um in a writer's room sometimes
you're working 10 or 12 hour a day you
know you don't really know when the day
going to end it depends on the room that
you're in it really it really could vary
there's not a lot of structure uh to how
writer rooms works it's all about what
the showrunner wants to do and how they
want to run the room
so
you I think going in knowing that is
helpful so that you can choose if that's
something that you would like um and if
you know that that's something that you
don't like um then you can use your
skills to create a lifestyle that is
more conducive to you that where work
Works around you and not you having to
fit yourself into work what about with
standup do you have to answer to the
audience um no that's what I love about
standup um but more and more we might
have to answer to the algorithm because
you know I'm noticing in my standup
because I usually swear a lot uh and I'm
noticing
that things I'm not as comfortable
sharing things on social media where I'm
swearing as much as I was before you
know I was really putting my work up on
social media so I definitely think
that I'm like oh I kind of want I want
this to be accessible to people I don't
want people to not watch it just because
I say the f word or like some bad word
you know like I and if that is not
integral to the joke then I'd rather
just not swear so I am finding that it I
have had somebody in the audience come
up to me after and tell me that they
didn't like that I swore and I did not
care but now I'm like okay I can
consider this a little bit more now I'm
a little bit
more aware of what
people are okay with but I don't think
that it's like changed my comedy it's
just made me think twice about do I need
to swear or
not